even when they're axed in spectacularly
gory fashion a fallen star of The
Walking Dead gets to walk away with a
major feather in their cap for being on
one of TV's most popular programs here's
a look at what's happened did these
killed off Walking Dead actors since
they departed the show love him or hate
him Jon Bernthal Shane Walsh was a very
big deal in The Walking Dead's
earliest seasons shortly after his
departure from the show Bernthal starred
in Martin Scorsese's the wolf of Wall
Street as quaaludes supplier Brad Banach
he also landed the leading role in mob
city from original Walking Dead
showrunner Frank Darabont and continued
to impress in cinematic action fare like
fury and baby driver apart from his
Walking Dead role though Bernthal is
perhaps best known for his turn as Frank
Castle in Marvel's The Punisher for
Netflix Sarah Wayne Callies Laurie
Grimes was another divisive but
paramount part of The Walking Dead's
initial run though she was initially
hesitant to take on another TV role
after The Walking Dead she landed a
leading role in USA Network's alien
invasion series colony which lasted for
three seasons soon after she also
reprised her most noteworthy pre dead
role in Fox's Prison Break revival while
most of the Walking Dead's death bound
cast members get a call from the
showrunners to let them know that
characters are being killed off it was
Jeffrey deMunn who did the dialing about
Dale's fate the actor had a long working
relationship with Frank Darabont and
said he was furious about how Darabont
had been pushed out of the show after
its inaugural season so he quit it
didn't take long for Daman to reconnect
with Darabont demun starred as police
chief Hal Morrison in Darabont's
short-lived noir series mob city he's
branched out into other TV projects
since then as well after enjoying guest
roles on several popular series deMunn
became a regular on Showtime's billions
as the central characters father Chuck
Rhodes senior Laurie Holden was also one
of the Walking Dead's initial cast
members who had a prior working
relationship with Darabont on the mist
but the death of Andrea wasn't as
instantaneous as Dales in fact she
became an important factor in season
three's war with the governor until she
faced an especially gnarly demise at the
hands of his real wake and henchmen
since her Walking Dead departure Holden
enjoyed a recurring role on FX as the
Americans as Renee the new wife of the
series central FBI agent who spoilers
may or may not have actually been a
Russian spy
she also has a recurring role on Fox's
legal drama proven innocent unlike most
of the earliest characters in The
Walking Dead Merle Dixon did not first
come from the comics and was instead an
original creation of the show actor
Michael Rooker had never struggled to
secure work before but things really
started to take off after The Walking
Dead in fact he may be even better known
for his work in the MCU as guardians of
the galaxy's yondu than Merle he's also
since starred in films like the Belko
experiment in HBO's third season of True
detective as The Walking Dead's first
major antagonist the governor brought a
lot of shocking moments to the screen
since he left the Walking Dead david
morrissey has continued to impress on
the small screen starting with a regular
role as Tobias Shepard on the second
season of sci-fi series extant
interestingly enough that allowed him to
work with Jeffrey Dean Morgan who would
later become the Walking Dead's mega
villain negan before he joined the rest
of the survivors as Tyreese Williams
Chad L Coleman was already known for his
performance as Dennis Cudi Weiss on
HBO's the wire since his time on dead
came to a heartbreaking end Coleman has
continued to amass impressive TV credits
in addition to enjoying recurring roles
on several popular TV shows Coleman
joined the cast of the expanse as carnal
Fred Johnson who becomes known as the
butcher of Anderson station for his
ruthless attack on a group of insurgents
Coleman also appears as the alien Clyde
anon Fox's the Orville or Bob when the
survivors sought refuge at terminus it
was Bob who was made to pay for that
mistake more than anyone else he was
forced to give a pound of flesh
several pounds actually to satisfy the
hunger of the crazy cannibals who had
tricked the group but he turned out to
be tainted meat in addition to a role on
HBO's The Deuce actor Laurence Gilyard
jr. another wire alum also earned a
recurring role in USA Network's final
season of Graceland if you don't get a
chill thinking back on Gareth behavior
in The Walking Dead's fourth and fifth
seasons you might be as inhumane as he
was since his character's brutal
on-screen execution Andrew J Wes has
made some interesting career moves first
he continued in the vein of villainy as
Damon on freeform short-lived horror
series dead of summer but then he showed
everyone that he could totally play the
good guy by becoming the adult version
of Henry mills in ABC's final season of
once upon a time as divisive as Deanna
for some fans of the walking dead she
eventually wised up and seated all her
authority in Alexandria to Rick Grimes
so in the end she definitely did not
deserve what was coming to her in season
six and her death was pretty sad things
have been going just swimmingly for Tova
feldsher in real life though the actress
has since earned several recurring roles
on new shows including playing the
President of the United States on CBS's
salvation and guest starring as Rachel
blooms overbearing mother on the CW's
crazy ex-girlfriend after his beloved
character Glenn was killed off in the
premiere of season 7 Steven Yeun made
some big moves to capitalize on a small
screen fame first he appeared in a few
movies including Netflix's okhta sorry
to bother you and the critically
acclaimed Korean film burning his TV
cred is only going to increase - as he
stars in an episode of Jordan peels
reboot of The Twilight Zone
he's also set to perform in another
property based on the comics of Robert
Kirkman the animated superhero series
invincible Glen might have run out of
luck on the show but his real-life
counterpart is doing just fine
like Glen Abraham and his epic mustache
were both grossly mistreated by negan's
batting practice session at the
beginning of season 7 actor Michael
Cudlitz journeyed back to Alexandria to
jump behind the lens and direct an
episode for season 9 and signed on to do
so again for season 10 the long working
actor has also had no trouble getting
jobs that put him in front of the lens
including guest roles and House of Lies
and young Sheldon and a regular role as
the Cleary family patriarch and ABC's
The Kids Are Alright Jesse was eaten
alive by walkers in season six while
experiencing the anguish of watching her
son get devoured right in front of her
because the Walking Dead simply has no
cap on cruelty TV fans are most likely
to recognize Alexandra Breckenridge from
NBC's hit drama series this is us which
introduced her as Kevin Pearson's
longtime love interest Sophie she's also
appeared on American Horror Story coven
and leaves the cast of Netflix's drama
series virgin River a few months before
Sasha's final episode aired the news
dropped that Sonique wa Martin Green had
landed the leading role of Michael
Burnham in CBS's Star Trek Discovery
which made her exit from The Walking
Dead seemed inevitable Martin greens
career shows no signs of slowing as
discovery has been renewed for a third
season and she's been tapped to star in
the sequel to Space Jam
last but not least let's pour one out
for poor Dwayne Jones the kiddo only
appeared in the very first episode of
the walking dead but his presence was
pivotal to establishing the mood of the
series since the show actor Adrian
Callie Turner has continued to work
steadily in films and TV including
appearing in the pilot for don't trust
the B in apartment 23 and in bad teacher
with Cameron Diaz Turner has grown up
quite a bit since his days in the
walking dead and even recently shared a
photo of himself holding a little Dwayne
doll for old times sake check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]